in dortmund liefern sich familien einen
blutigen kampf um die düngerpreise neben
einer schusswaffe kamen auch schon lange
döner messer zum einsatz
andreas wegner berichtet
[Musik]
augenzeugen videos zeigen aufruhr in der
rheinstraße in dortmund im mittelpunkt
zwei verfeindete der dönerladen
betreiber der anlass die düngerpreise
kein scherz am ende fallen schüsse ein
döner messe wird geschwungen drei
beteiligte müssen ins krankenhaus
nur 64 schritte liegen zwischen diesen
dönerladen und einem konkurrenten in der
gleichen straße in dortmund was aber die
preispolitik angehen da liegen welten
zwischen den beiden betrieben denn zum
zweiten mal sind mitarbeiter dieser
läden jetzt auf offener straße
aneinander geraten und haben sich eine
regelrechte straßenschlacht geliefert
wie einen augenzeugen video zeigt dabei
ist deutlich zu sehen dass die männer
nicht nur mit teller nacheinander waffen
sondern auch mit einem langen messer und
sogar mit einer schusswaffe aufeinander
losgehen nach bild informationen sind
zwei männer schwer verletzt worden einer
erlitt ein schuss ins bein
nur eine schnittverletzung am handgelenk
die beiden verloren sehr viel blut und
mussten ins krankenhaus
die polizei kommt zum einsatzort sperrte
straßen ab mehrere beteiligte werden
festgenommen die kriminalpolizei
dortmund ermittelt derzeit wegen
gefährlicher körperverletzung in diesem
zusammenhang wurden vier tatverdächtige
ermittelt sie sind im alter von 21 bis
50 jahren alt und gegen einen
40-jährigen mann erlebte man ein
haftbefehl außer vollzug gesetzt wurde
[Musik]
inzwischen sind die leute vernommen
worden man hat ihnen klar gemacht dass
es so auf gar keinen fall weitergeht
einer musste sogar fast ins gefängnis
konnte nur im letzten moment verhindern
mit seinem anwalt das es so weit kommt
und er verschont worden aber für die
leute muss jetzt klar sein so geht das
hier nicht weiter und die betriebe man
sieht dass hier sind noch immer
geschlossen
[Musik]
bild erfuhr offenbar ging es um den
preis von döner taschen in dem einen
laden kostet sie über vier euro in den
anderen drei euro fünfzig egal ob
mädchen oder kalbfleisch schafskäse
kostet extra ob das allerdings der
alleinige hintergrund ist dass wagen die
ermittler der polizei nach bild
informationen zu bezweifeln denn das
soll noch ganz andere sachen geben die
hier grund für die konflikte sein können
zunächst kann nach bild-informationen
auch ein clown oder rocker hintergrund
nicht ausgeschlossen werden es ist also
noch gar nichts geklärt zwischen den
zwei döner ladenbetreiber familien der
nächste streit lässt trotz aller
ermahnungen bestimmt nicht lange auf
sich warten
bei dieser auseinandersetzung am 21
november auf der rheinischen straße in
dortmund wurden drei männer mit schnitt
und schussverletzungen ins krankenhaus
gebracht die staatsanwaltschaft und die
polizei bittet jetzt um zeugenaussagen
hinweise zur tat bitte an die polizei
unter 0231 132
74 41